the Duke of Sussex has faced another day
of forensic cross-examination in court
love interests drug taking and being
chased by the paparazzi with a focus of
the questioning on day two there are no
cameras and no recordings allowed in
court but we'll bring you the highlights
of the evidence in a reconstruction
played by an actor this is Harry in
court a Sky News special
Prince Harry is due to take to the
witness stand for a second day he wanted
to expose wrongdoing and he wants to
hold those responsible accountable the
offense surrounding his mother's death
presents the media the king damages
claims against the mirror group
you've heard how alleged hacking
engulfed his whole life
Harry's court papers make huge
allegations this is Prince Harry versus
the papers round three
hello there good evening I'm Jonathan
Samuels and this week Prince Harry has
been questioned for nearly eight hours
by lawyers history was made when the
Duke of Sussex took to the witness box
the first senior Royal to do so since
the 19th century Harry is accusing
mirror group newspapers the proprietor
and publisher of the Daily Mirror the
Sunday Mirror and the Sunday people of
unlawful information gathering between
1991 and 2011 which his legal team says
resulted in a number of Articles being
published arriving once again to a media
frenzy outside of Courts ultimately it's
the prince who has to prove his case but
has he done enough to convince the judge
will bring you what was said in court
played by an actor
throughout this program we'll be getting
the thoughts from our expert panel
Persephone Bridgeman Baker media lawyer
and partner at Carter Ruck and Paul con
you former editor of the Sunday Mirror
and Deputy editor of the Daily Mirror
great to see you both again we will chat
in a moment first of all though let's
take a look at what was said in court
the second day of the prince's
cross-examination began with a look at
articles published during Harry's time
in the armed forces now this piece from
May 2005 it was published in the people
newspaper claimed Cadets at the
Sandhurst Military Academy were furious
with Harry after he was let off daily
exercise on account of an injured knee
uh yes it is entirely accurate that's in
reference to while it was at Sandhurst
and the distrust I ended up having while
I was at Sandhurst the Barrister then
says but in any event the injury to your
knee was public knowledge and you
discussed it publicly uh yes then Andrew
Green raised some other articles about
Prince Harry's knee injury before saying
a senior officer had raised the issue
that other Cadets might feel you were
getting preferential treatment yes do
you accept there is public interest in
reporting preferential treatment no I
don't
showing the courtroom another article
this time about Harry's drug taking Mr
Green follows up with I think you were
suggesting it was not a public interest
story I didn't say that I said there was
a difference between public interest and
what interests the public I don't
believe it affects the well-being of
society the lawyer for the newspaper
group pushes the prince to Define what
is in the public interest asking what
would be a public interest story about
you which would be legitimate to publish
I'm not entirely sure other than
speculating could you speculate for a
moment what would be a public interest
story in your view a life-threatening
injury a life-threatening injury but
short of that I'm sure there are others
but
going back to the Sandhurst article the
Barrister suggests it was inevitable
that other Cadets would pay attention to
how the Duke was being treated Prince
Harry replied with yes the Barrister
adding and other Cadets would pay
attention to how you were being treated
at Sandhurst yes and I could save a lot
of time by talking more about the
article itself as opposed to just the
knee injury well to that Andrew Green
responds with could I ask the questions
and then perhaps you before the judge
into Jack saying you put your questions
Mr Green and then Prince Harry will be
given the opportunity to answer them my
Lord Andrew Green continues and if
someone thought you were getting unfair
preferential treatment they might well
ask about it and disclose it to the
media it would be if those grueling
marches were happening at that period of
time yes
so in that exchange they referred to the
witness statement which we can show you
now it reads I was not going around
freely discussing any medical issues or
injuries that I had I was almost
conditioned to feel guarded at this
point in my life worrying I couldn't
trust anyone for fear that it would end
up splashed across the tabloids well
let's speak to Persephone and Paul uh
before we get into all of that there's a
lot to discuss Persephone you're in
court again today what was the
atmosphere like and how was Harry so we
had reporters outside from all over the
world today which is quite quite
astonishing quite a relatively small
space outside the Rose Building
um and the atmosphere in Court's day was
different from yesterday I think it was
quite clear that yesterday's rigorous
questioning by the mirrors Barrister had
taken its toll on Harry today and I mean
you know you're tired you've had to go
away and not talk to anybody about your
evidence quite a stressful situation to
be held overnight when you're a witness
and that really showed us yeah there was
a little bit there wasn't there where
the judge had to to step in at one stage
about the questioning
um Paul Harry said when it comes to
stories uh about the rules only a
life-threatening injury makes the grade
I mean what would you make of that yes I
I think I mean it's one of the great
dilemmas of course of you know what is
the public interest as opposed to the
you know the interesting what interests
the public and and Harry's obviously
aware of that but I think just to say a
life-threatening injury is that the only
thing of course is you know I mean he he
could have said well if I was involved
in in some disciplinary for misconduct
or whatever as an example but I think he
I I think he's uh arguing that virtually
everything should be private unless it's
you know on a on a massive scale if
they'd like like his his you know fallen
over and except a brain injury and yet
when you read his book there's plenty uh
more stories in it than life threatening
exactly I mean the the invading his own
privacy argument of course is there the
Piers Morgan defense yeah and Persephone
when it comes to the public interest is
that actually relevant in in this case
it is although it's it's been of limited
priority really because the mirror's
main defenses that the unlawful
information gathering didn't take place
so we don't really get to a public
interest argument although it has sprung
up in in places um over the course of
the proceedings he's clearly got a chip
on his shoulder hasn't he about so many
issues and we talked a bit about it
yesterday
um when he goes back to Sandhurst he's
clearly frustrated at the thought that
he might have got preferential treatment
but he might have been let off things
that his mates were having to do
I think it's more a case that
if he is telling the truth or all that
terrible thing his own truth it's the
fact that he he he felt that the the
media would would would portray it that
way even even if the the military
weren't saying that I mean it's part of
this I mean he used the word paranoia a
couple of times a day I think the royal
family might be quite relieved in that
one sense he's now saying that he's
paranoia that it was member of his own
family who were leaking to the Press he
said you know he no longer believes that
so uh whether that's going to lead to
any sort of
partial reproachment who knows and I
suppose it's all about whether unlawful
information gathering was used or
whether it was tip-offs from other
squadies from members of staff at places
like Santos that's sort of the Crux of
it isn't it yes about whether the
information was already in the public
domain because it had been published by
third party Publishers or whether or not
it came from leaks within the Royal
press team or from some of it some of
them in related to actually interviews
that Harry's given himself I mean not
involving Prince Harry but in the past
I've known um should we say sources with
with who are upset or feel you know
maligned or leaking stories are from you
know by Sanders Cadet so it's not an
it's not an unknown phenomenon that uh
you know the paper could have got it
from a disgruntled mem you know member
of the son of student body Harry spoke
about some of the information today
saying that at the time when it was
published he thought it must have been
through leaks so clearly at the time
that's something which you know they are
they're aware of it happening yeah they
really are um thank you both for the
moment coming up we'll be getting the
thoughts of a rule Insider who used to
work for his father now King Charles
now later in cross-examination the Duke
makes a claim that phone hacking stemmed
right across the Tabloid News Press
I believe there is phone hacking at an
industrial scale across at least three
of the papers of the time and that is
beyond doubt
and to have a decision against me and
any other people who come behind me with
their claims given that mirror group
newspapers have admitted hacking and
they have given out I believe over a
billion in settlements yes I would feel
some injustice if it wasn't accepted
under green the Barrister for the mirror
then says I see so you want to have been
phone hacked and nobody wants to have
been phone hacked my Lord
well one line of attack from the
Barrister for the mirror group
newspapers was to question why Prince
Harry didn't consider phone hacking
years before now the Barrister showed
this article Shell Shocked asking Harry
do you recall talking to the Met police
in relation to this
no I don't it all went through the
palace and presumably the palace would
have handed over your relevant phone
records hopefully not my voicemails
the lawyer clarifies sorry not your
voicemails uh I would assume I'm not
entirely sure it was all out of my hands
Andrew Green references the arrests in
2006 a private investigator Glenmore
care and News of the World reporter
Clive Goodman for phone hacking and are
you aware that no other journalists were
arrested at this time there were no
arrests of any mirror journalists are
you aware of that oh yes the Barrister
adds presumably from that time on you
and your aides would have been straight
off to the police if any information
from your voicemail turned up in the
papers uh again not necessarily and I
very rarely saw any of my phone records
because they were managed by the palace
Andrew Green continues to question
Prince Harry saying you would know what
voicemail had been left on your phone
and would know if that information would
have been picked up wouldn't you no my
Lord at the time we didn't know it was
voicemail hacking no one did it seemed
suspicious that Clive Goodman wrote the
story that he did and that it was
connected no one really knew at the time
Andrew Green then suggests Prince Harry
must have known the Articles were as a
result of phone hacking after the
journalists went to prison I believe the
understanding within the palace was this
was probably a one-off and I believe it
was described as a one-off as well
fascinating exchange that wasn't it in
court earlier today Persephone timing is
very interesting it's come up quite a
lot hasn't it over the last couple of
days because Andrew Green making the
point there we know people being
arrested for phone hacking and going to
prison and yet you still didn't suspect
you were being phone hacked at that
stage that's absolutely right it goes
back to the this limitation defense
point where you're you're supposed to
bring these sorts of claims in relation
to misuse of private information within
six years under our limitation Act and
when you that's six years from the date
on which you found out about um the
incidents taking place or should have
reasonably found out about the incidents
taking place and really it puts both
parties at a disadvantage we've seen
both parties today have difficulties
with Recollections difficulties with
deleted material and destroyed evidence
and that's part of the reason why those
limitation periods exist I found it very
interesting that the very last thing the
judge said to Harry just before he left
the witness box was to
refer to four paragraphs the judge said
hadn't really been discussed that much
from his statement and it was the four
paragraphs relating you know two
to his voicemail messages disappearing
and not just his but those of people he
was in you know in contact with him and
and saying when did you first realize or
become suspicious that something might
be happening and Harry said you know
when I was 13 at Eaton
uh and they didn't really follow through
on that but I was fascinated why he but
he seized on those on those four packets
oh he was the judge always said do you
think it continued and Harry said yes
it's con I now think it's continued ever
since do you think we've seen hard
evidence Persephone today I don't feel
we saw any yesterday necessarily but do
you think we've seen hard evidence today
of unlawful information gathering uh
with any of the Articles they've been
through I don't I don't think it's
really it's changed today I mean I think
we said yesterday that I think that the
blagging point is arguably the strongest
the Articles where that bagging seems to
have been a source of the material today
Harry actually said there's hard
evidence of an incredible amount of
suspiciousness which I think really sums
up his case actually that this is just
an inferential case based on what they
say is an enormous amount of
circumstantial material yeah I mean as a
journalist it's not a lawyer are they 33
stories I think there are maybe four the
most five where I would I would guess
that uh Harry might have a fighting
chance of winning on the rest I think I
think it'd be almost impossible for the
for the judge to decide these were the
you know were they out with the outcome
of either phone hacking or blogging and
the ones either way I think he's got a
fighting chance I are mainly blagging
rather than phone hugging he only needs
one really doesn't he we only want us to
yeah it's like a penalty shootout isn't
it yeah I mean Harry would have would
hail won as a major victory but of
course for the mirror even one would be
a disaster because and they've got three
more of course to come in this in this
case
um they have I think between 80 and 100
more in the pipeline and when the mirror
settled in a blaze of publicity in 2015
the share price was hit badly so it's
not just a question of reputation it's
not just a question of what they may
have to pay out should you know should
Harry and the others win this case is
what the impact it could have you know
on the share price and the little stat I
was looking at a bit about my own
research
at the time Harry first now claims he
you know the hacking began
The Daily Mirror circulation was 2
million it's now down to less than 400
000 which which shows the economic you
know yeah well we're in a really
different world doesn't it and and just
finally Persephone on that point do you
think the world has moved on
um and actually the influence of the
press isn't as great now as it as it
once was and that's not helping uh
Harry's argument when it comes to the
General Public
I don't know about that
um I think that the Press still has
enormous interest I think it influence
it I think it's just it's shaped in a
different way now isn't it I mean we
consume so much more at high speed
online it's very different from when you
see these old hard copy articles that's
a real throwback isn't it although
although I think the influence is you
know politicians I think are slow to
realize that the influence is not as
great as it was I was watching it on a
different Channel Andrew Neal this
morning who was basically
saying that you know Harry really you
know shouldn't be bothered because the
papers now matter so little you know
that he's already won in circulation
yeah it's a very good point and perhaps
uh one for a longer debate another time
thank you both very much for the moment
uh after the break we'll bring you
Harry's explosive accusations about how
phone hacking started at the mirror and
what happened when the mirror journalist
took the stand
foreign
[Music]
the pound has rallied moderation
interest rates peaking up and up at six
percent the highest for 14 years will
that be the peak will it be a little bit
lower prices it's closer to a potential
crash so many words so many meanings but
what do they mean for you and your
finances stay up to date on Sky News I'm
Lisa Dowd and I'm Skye's Midlands
correspondent we can reveal that the
driver who hit Harry Dunn is 42 year old
and sakulas just met the president and
who never thought we'd get this far this
is what they're up against is
back-breaking work
water levels are dropping but no one
knows what impact further rain will have
what would you do if this place wasn't
opened so
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
it's really scary in this community I'm
told that everybody knows someone
affected by covid change seems
tantalizingly close in this corner of
the UK this is my patch my specialism
it's also my home
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
hello again welcome back to this special
program now throughout this hour we will
keep bringing you our reconstruction of
Harry's second day of evidence in court
as the cross-examination continued the
lawyer for the mirror group pressed the
Duke of Sussex on whether he could ever
identify any story where their
journalists used phone hacking that's a
question for my legal team there's hard
evidence to suggest an incredible amount
of suspiciousness and I believe that the
burner phones were used excessively at
mirror group the Barrister responds but
you haven't identified in respect of any
of the 33 articles we've been through I
believe phone hacking started at mirror
group any particular info from a mobile
phone that went into the story you have
I can't remember a specific voicemails
that I left over the last 20 years
Andrew Green then asks the Duke if it's
right the first time he approached his
lawyer was to discuss the mirror group
newspapers or another newspaper group
I think it was discussed on how to find
a way to put the abuse intrusion and
hate that was coming towards me and
coming to me and my wife and to try and
find a way to stop it rather than
relying on the institution's lawyers
I presume by the time you went to
solicitors you'd known for many years
the news of the world had intercepted
your phone hadn't you I was aware of one
article the Clive Goodman article and
when did you first learn there was
relevant call data relating to newsgroup
I can't remember
the Barrister then accuses Harry of
first deciding to sue News Group
newspapers before bringing a claim
against mgn no I believe I filed the
claims at pretty much the same time
Andrew Green then asks if he knew there
was no call data at the time the claims
were filed there was industrial scale
destruction of evidence on all sides so
where do you get this idea of
destruction of evidence from Mirror
group from my legal team
um let's speak to our experts Paul and
Persephone so Persephone he's flown all
the way from La he's been fighting this
for years he's got his moment in court
and when he's asked where's the evidence
where's the link to phone hacking to any
of these articles he says ask my legal
team it's the case entirely based on
inference and the circumstantial
evidence which he's he's seeking to
build and there is no hard evidence of
any hacking or blagging in relation to
any of these specific 33 articles and we
we see more of that when we come on to
the care evidence later but he says the
mirror is where it all started what's he
basing that on a very good question I
you know I have no idea because the
first I think any of us including
including most uh most of us in in the
jalistic world knew about phone hacking
was with you know certain people you
know was in fact the Clive Goodman case
which he mentioned so what so whether he
misspoke or I don't know but but
the idea began at the mirror I'm not
quite sure where he's actually getting
that from or whether that's what he
meant to to say or you know or not but
you know it was curious it was curious I
mean he's he's right in the sense that
but this is with hindsight he's right to
say that there was industrial scale
hacking at the mirror because as
admitted that in the in the 100 million
pound settlements they've already uh
paid out and they're seeking to make
that leap isn't he to say Well it has
happened in other instances and we've
had those 2015 cases where the hacking
was found to have occurred and that must
mean that it happened in my case as well
that unfortunately I don't necessarily
think that there's any hard evidence
that we've seen that that gets him there
but the circumstantial evidence may be
enough yeah I mean the judge is going to
have to it I mean this is as we as we've
said before at the end of the day the
judge is going to be heavily weighing up
the inferences and how and how much that
is going to guide his final decision
yeah a quick legal question Persephone
and and uh we we don't know whether the
mirror group has ever said to Prince
Harry look we'll settle out of court
um but we know that has happened with
plenty of other cases what happens if uh
an organization says we want to settle
um and yet the person says well I don't
I want my day in court then does that
organization have to go to court they do
yes
um and in this instance Harry said very
firmly that he doesn't want a financial
settlement that's not what he's looking
for he always wanted his day in court so
the likelihood of this case settling um
was very low but I do think that the
mayor is hoping obviously if they can
have a good result in this case it might
lead to assessments down the line and
the other 100 plus cases which are still
together that can work the other way of
course if if Harry wins at all then it's
gonna it's going to open the floodgates
but you know in terms of the other
atrial yeah yeah very interesting okay
well we'll have that much more from
Harry in a moment but we should talk a
bit about uh what happened in court
after Harry finished giving evidence
what was interesting he actually stayed
in court to listen now a number of the
articles that formed Prince Harry's case
against mgn were written by the daily
mirrors former Royal correspondent and
assistant editor Jane Kerr she also gave
evidence this afternoon and denied she
closed her eyes to alleged phone hacking
well this is what she said in a witness
statement I've never engaged in
voicemail interception at MGM or
elsewhere and I have never engaged the
services of private investigators or
other third parties to engage in
unlawful information gathering
activities in a second statement she
said I worked hard and honestly as a
journalist always believing I was doing
the right thing and I felt proud and
privileged to be the mirrors War
reporter to be accused of such a thing
is extremely upsetting and Paul when she
took the stand the very first question
was you don't want to be here do you I
mean that was the dramatic opening to
the after the afternoon and when it also
emerged that she was there because the
judge had actually ordered to be there
which is quite an unusual situation in a
civil case like this so I think that was
a dramatic start and
and I think that
what we saw there was in was David
Sherborne doing the same rather
aggressive but skillful
cross-examination that he did but you
know when he uh rather crushed Rebecca
Valley and uh and I think we're going to
see more see more of that tomorrow
because she's going to be back in the
Box again for another 90 for another 90
minutes so uh I don't envy her that
um well one of the interesting bits
today
one of one of the most interesting was
when she was talked about phone calls
that she used to make to a private
investigator now in court they said
there were 900 phone calls but she said
not on one occasion did she ask what
methods were being used in order for
that private investigator to gather the
information that she needed and that was
the Crux of Harry's legal teams of the
bastards questions today was how can you
have made that authoritative statement
that you make in your witness statement
um that says that I've never engaged in
in hacking of any sort when actually you
weren't asking the right questions were
you was it not your responsibility to be
saying to this private investigator well
how are you providing me with X
directory numbers how are you providing
me with phone bills with flight details
and those were the sorts of questions
which were being asked today and that's
where that comment came are you just
closing your eyes to this and in and
also of course the David Sherborne was
making a play of the fact that and I
think he'll come back to this tomorrow
is that okay you didn't we did two
statements the first one didn't include
you know certain names and then and then
she also this might be an oversight but
he'll make more of it that she'd only
mentioned which was the royal editor in
her statement not that she was an
assistant editor and of course David
sherbold is trying to say well that's a
more senior role you're on the news desk
your desk desk so you know what what did
you think you know these you know who
was who was who was actually asking you
to actually
commission this and didn't you ask why
they yeah and you were an editor Paul
you know you've run newspapers did you I
don't know what to the actual
culture was in terms of you know at the
time of you know because jenko never
wasn't wasn't there never worked for me
but I've only met her once or twice
socially but in fact
if any of the stories of the 33 stories
you know a lot of them were quite fluffy
and hardly worth hacking words
but there were some where as an editor I
would want to know what is our sourcing
for this you know how do we you know if
challenged how do we Justified that's
point one and secondly we were coming
out of the Maxwell pension fund Scandal
and so one of the shareholders were
demanding tough budget trees yeah so you
know I would be asked to explain well if
you want to spend this much money on X
so why are you paying somebody this
amount of money and so I think this is
somewhere that sure will return to
tomorrow we need to go to a break in a
second but Persephone do you think that
she did well on the stand today how do
you feel that she coped and how do you
think she'll do tomorrow what do you
think it was quite obviously she didn't
really want to want to be there but she
dealt with the questions very well but I
think you're right I think she's going
to get get held up on those sorts of
points about why wasn't she asking these
questions and really if you're spending
this much money on external third
parties what were you getting for it you
must have been getting something and in
order for your editors to continue to
learn it's about to say to her well you
know weren't you aware that that some of
the people you you were authorizing
payments to or being asked to welfare's
payments to you know were actually
people who were named in the motor mount
inquiry by the information commission's
office back in back in 2003 you know so
um okay listen we're out of time we must
go to a break thank you both for the
moment uh we will have more of our
reconstruction of Prince Harry in court
right the way through the program stay
with us coming up after the break the
moment the court delves further into
Harry's love life and what was written
about his relationships plus we're going
to get an account from someone who
worked for Charles before he became king
don't go away
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hello again welcome back to this special
program where we bring you all the
highlights from Prince Harry in court
played by an actor well Harry's past
relationships were always big business
weren't they for the newspapers and
Andrew Green Casey who represents the
mirror group brought up an article with
the headline hurray Harris dumped it
claimed Chelsea became tired of Harry's
boozy lifestyle and lack of commitment
uh yes I think I'm right and saying my
Lord that Dan Evans gave his testimony
and talked about that there was 35 to 40
minutes between the first edition and
the follow-up in order to create or
carry on the story I'm just referencing
it it was the first edition and it was
on the same day just something that came
into my mind
so the Barrister question whether that
was a result of phone hacking uh it's
very sauce yes but you don't know whose
phones would have been hacked for that
purpose no and I believe I've answered
that my Lord
the photo itself in the article even
States pictures on a previous night out
I don't know how photographers knew I
was going to be there the article refers
to me going to be there and yet there
were no photographs of the evening
Here Andrew Green asks whether or not
Prince Harry has read the article
something he's repeatedly asked
throughout the cross-examination no but
again once I look through it now going
through it now
who Ray Harry's dumped was hurtful to
say the least such a private moment was
turned into a bit of a laugh the fact
that payments were referenced to project
Harry is incredibly disturbing yeah it
is it's the level of surveillance I was
under was quite something the Barrister
asks you're not suggesting the reference
to hurray Harry is celebrating you've
been dumped are you uh yes I am and then
suggests you don't think it's a
reference to hooray Harry it's a name
you had to some extent I'm not entirely
sure when hooray Harry began
I think it may even have been referred
to in one of the other articles we
looked at in the news of the world
again my Lord if it has been used before
me as the subject or or victim of this
to see that word used in this term is
hurtful
hurtful well Persephone Bridgeman Baker
and Paul konyu are still with me I'm
going to speak to them again in a moment
but right now I'm very pleased to say
that I'm joined by Christina kariaki
former Communications secretary to
Charles between 2009 and 2016 before he
became king great to see you thank you
very much isn't it fascinating listening
to what Harry had to say in court
um the tone of some of these articles
clearly really upset him um when you
were working for the royal family did
you feel that they felt the pressure of
the media the pressure of the newspapers
on their shoulders
life of
Purvis they're born into a life of
publicity they are there to serve the
British public and I think a lot of that
has got gotten forgotten with this court
case it's as if Harry doesn't remember
that he was born into a life of public
service now I appreciate that he you
know he didn't have any Sayo for that
that's the life he was born into but
it's as if he doesn't feel that any of
his life should be made public and he
talks about a hostile media being
hostile to him since he was born
I don't have any recollection in recent
years of any royal baby that wasn't
celebrated by media all over the world
so I don't know where this hostility set
in and when his first recollection was
but what I do know is that there was a
deep suspicion and paranoia of media
that Harry fostered and and to a certain
extent William did which seemed to have
come from the uh untimely death of their
mother
and I think a lot of what Harry's
talking about in court is supposition
it's almost you know he's he's recalling
things that he's heard he's he thinks
have upset him that he's read and he's
he feels targeted
um well what about the source of those
stories
um how tight are the Palaces I mean
surely stuff leaks all the time doesn't
it from members of Staff very very sadly
it does Jonathan yes and nothing is
private in life and certainly since the
Advent of social media absolutely
nothing is private and of course with
members of the royal family there's
always someone around so there's private
staff and there's a professional staff
and you know there's always a butler
there'll be
um a serving staff there'll be a cook
there'll be a nanny there's people
coming in and out like any other busy
household nothing is private there's
security staff there's drivers and so
again I've I've often during the past
two days heard Prince Harry reference
that he just can't possibly think how
these stories could have got into the
public domain I've got a very good idea
because it was a leaky sieve and I feel
the
um under my jurisdiction reform had
happened with the media so post Princess
Diana's death we had the levison inquiry
and one does need to remember that the
most recent of these articles that Harry
is questioning is 2011. so post the
death of Diana there was reform and we
didn't really see the paparazzi
intrusion that the papers have admitted
to and again as all the guests have said
as you have said yourself newspaper
figures have dwindled so this all feels
a little bit after the event and it all
feels a bit woe is me when ultimately
most of his life was supposed to be in
public service and now it isn't he's not
a working member of the royal family but
we know that he I mean he's had a
terrible time with the paparazzi hasn't
he being chased and and we know what
happened to his mother of course it's
understandable isn't it that he's got
this this Grudge he's had a really tough
time yes he's had a tough time but he
doesn't seem to remember any of the
moments that were celebrated I mean
Invictus games was the most celebrated
charitable initiative and that was all
Harry championing that and that I I mean
I can remember the most glorious spread
of media for him globally printed media
broadcast media and he seems to have
forgotten I just think it's a very very
one-sided Viewpoint and I appreciate
he's in court to talk about 33 articles
but what we have seen not just in court
but with spare the interviews all of the
thing things that he's done in the past
year is he seems very very unhappy yeah
he's unhappy about that Obsession that
the Tabloid the tablet price did have an
obsession with him didn't they um we've
only got a few seconds left but I wanted
to know what you think Charles makes of
the last few days I think you know as as
I know the king I believe he will be
hoping that Harry gets the outcome that
he wants and that that puts this sort of
Suspicion to bed and that Harry can be a
happier person
King Charles does not follow the media
avidly he learned that at a very very
young age and he has tried to teach his
sons that and so when I hear things
about the suicide mission that rumored
it's rumored that King Charles said
you're on a hiding to nothing yeah
exactly I I know that the king would
have just simply given advice try not to
read it try not to let it consume you
you know and so he will just be hoping
that this settles something for Harry
and that this literally is a fixation
that seems to have lasted the past 20 30
years
um Christina kiriaku a fascinating
Insight thank you very much thank you
John thank you thank you
well let's get more of what Prince Harry
had to say shall we kicking off his
re-examination the Duke's lawyer David
Sherborne turns to an article about the
TV presenter Caroline Flack it was
published in the people back in 2009.
the prince briefly dated Caroline Flack
you may remember that year Well Sherborn
then questioned his client about being
pursued by the paparazzi two individuals
I'm happy to name them if you wish uh
from icon pictures were well known to me
and my security team uh they stalked and
harassed us for well over a decade I say
us they also picked on my brother
they proved to be an enormous security
issue always turning up before we got
there it doesn't surprise me in this
case the journalists were relying on
Paparazzi as a source but also
intentionally misleading the readers
attributing it to an onlooker
David chairborne then asks you say they
always seem to be in places where you
were do you have any idea how they knew
where you were no but I am my whole
security team as well as my brother
suspected unlawful activities consistent
unlawful activity the added example was
I was at one of my friend Mark Dyer's
Pub who was having his phone hacked as I
looked out I looked down the road and I
saw what I recognized to be the silver
Freelander one of the photographers with
blacked out windows approximately 150
meters down the road
it had its window down slightly three
inches not enough to take photographs
but enough to observe
uh people carrier it's a security
vehicle has strobes it had blue flashing
lights uh when security approached it
slammed into reverse
I saw what I've seen drove off at speed
just off the embankment next to the boy
on the dolphin statue next to Albert
Bridge the police driving the vehicle
switched on the blue lights this this
vehicle decided to increase its speed uh
orange Bob
one of the protection officers uh went
to speak to the individual and he
decided to drive on to the other side of
the road endangering everyone around him
uh opposite fire station on Kings Road
and decided to evade police from asking
questions
that is not normal
Pap Behavior
we believe there was some kind of legal
device in that vehicle and that he was
given instructions no matter what not to
be stopped not to be searched but uh
my police had no ability to search them
well Persephone and Paul are still here
pretty uh strong story that wasn't it um
cross-examination over he's now been
questioned Again by his own lawyer back
on more comfortable ground yeah
re-examination at the moment to give
your client the opportunity to do that
which she certainly did letting him
speak in the way that he did know it was
a really emotive part of this morning I
thought
um but you know even during the parts he
was talking about about flag Harry came
back to the point that he thought that
this material came out as a result of a
leak and that perhaps it was someone on
Caroline's side who'd tipped off
photographers and we were talking
earlier weren't we about really
photographers you know camping ground
available around every corner if you
were to find someone and say there's a
no there's a member of the royal
household nearby so it's it's hard now
looking back to sort of put that in the
context of this the paparazzi funeral
whether we like at the time whether we
like it or or not if the weather is
Paparazzi who just spent their time
hanging around where they thought they
would find you know in Prince Harry's
case I don't I can't we don't know the
truth of the it was as dramatic as
Harris pointed out but but certainly
they would certainly they would Target
you know celebrities where they think
they might find them and Prince Harry
you know Center position it was a
celebrity as much as a royal enemy in
many people's eyes in you know in the
media but there was also another thing
that happened this morning which I I
I've searched through his statement and
also I've tried to Quick remind myself
of spare and going through it but he
also claimed that he he'd found a
tracking device on Chelsea Davis Car
well I I can't for the moment find any
previous reference to that but so it's
surprisingly he's that's suddenly a you
know come from nowhere yeah interesting
point that uh isn't it well before uh he
was questioned uh by his own lawyer his
cross-examination uh came to an end and
Andrew Green asked Prince Harry if he
has sued any other papers about
newspaper articles
in process Daily Record Daily Star no
not the Daily Record or Daily Star no
why not those I don't believe uh that
there was industrial scale phone hacking
at those Publications Andrew Green
responds with only industrial scale
phone hacking that and then Trails off
is Harry comes in with no I have no
reason at this point
I'm quite busy with other litigations my
Lord
okay we're going to take another break
when we come back we have the moment
Prince Harry gets emotional in the
witness box stay with us
[Music]
I smile Sometimes I Cry Sometimes I'm
I'm very happy that I was able to have
such a a long career with these songs
well you said I think you were the most
successful black pop group ever yes
that's what we were told after 22
billion hits on Tick Tock and
and every World everywhere in the world
people listen to our Songs amazing
what's your connection with Windrush my
father and my mother came to the UK in
the early 50s and I joined them later on
so my connection to Windrush is that I
am one of the wind Rush babies put it
that way
um some of them were left in the
Caribbean and never ever saw their
parents again fortunately for me and my
brothers we were able to join our
parents after a separation I think that
um
had this problem not happen that wind
Rush became wind Rush meaning people
were sent home and or sent back to the
Caribbean we wouldn't even be having
this conversation today and I'm very
grateful that we have this privilege to
talk about what it was like of course
when I came here
um as a as a young child
um intimidated by everything having to
get to know everyone even my my parents
my siblings that's my story but there
are many other people of the Windrush
generation who would have gone through
similar experiences either joining their
parents as I said or not being able to
join their parents growing up in school
we had to get to know the system had to
get to know to be to be received by the
system the teachers to like us or not to
like us to to Value us or not to value
US it was quite difficult I think for a
lot of us to assimilate to get into a
culture that we did not really know
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
welcome back to this Harry in court
special with his moment in the spotlight
coming to an end Prince Harry he really
grasped the opportunity to address the
judge directly my Lord my whole life the
Press have misled me covered up their
wrongdoing
to be sitting here in court knowing that
the defense has the evidence in front of
them and and green saying I'm
speculating
I'm not entirely sure what to say about
that
and in one of the final exchanges during
Prince Harry's time in the witness box
David Sherborne asks his client how
giving evidence in a public courtroom
for a day and a half had made him feel
this was his answer
um
it's a lot
Persephone Paul it's been great having
you with us over the last two or three
days thank you both very much indeed uh
just want to finish by bringing in our
Royal correspondent Laura bundock so
Laura we've heard all of Harry's
evidence you've been there all week
how's it gone for him
well he left court today didn't he with
that wave and a little smile but I think
a lot of relief that his time here was
over it is certainly not been easy for
him being cross-examined and that moment
there where is Barrister right at the
end asking the question how are you
feeling was so revealing that huge pause
Harry's been pretty quick with his
replies there was a huge pause this time
before he answered in a voice so faint a
lot of us in court couldn't even make
out what he had said it's a lot was the
reply because this has been a lot for
him he's taking this huge risk trying to
take on the tabloids but we've had a
real sense over the last couple of days
about the impact all these stories have
had on him and the strength of
conviction he has that he believes he
has this case this cause because of
course all of this was his choice but it
was also his chance to try and proving
Court the mirror group newspapers were
intruding into his private life by
unlawful means and over this long period
of time and he he also wants to hold
those responsible to account and we
heard today as well how he wants to stop
the hate against Megan but above all
that there is this much bigger purpose
for Harry he has pitched himself now as
a champion for change when it comes to
the media I think it will be interesting
even if he wins this case to see what he
ends up achieving because whilst he
might have this personal Crusade at the
moment the real challenge for him will
be to try and bring about some wider
reform and for that he will need to
gather and Garner a lot of support
support not just from the public but for
politicians as well if he is to bring
about any meaningful change anyway for
now he'll be heading back to the U.S
probably glad it's over but he will
simply have to wait there are three
other claimants in this case and they
will all take the witness stand over the
next couple of weeks and then the judge
will take his time before making a
ruling I think for now the royal family
certainly will be glad it's all over the
king famously once said to Harry about
his court cases he believed they were a
suicide mission and while it might take
a few months before we find out the
final ruling we will eventually know
whether or not the king was right or
wrong in saying that
we really will Laura bundock our Royal
correspondent thank you very much and
that is it the Duke of Sussex has
endured nearly eight hours of
questioning it's been heated at times
jokes were made and there were a lot of
awkward issues raised as well weren't
there and over the past few days here at
Sky News we wanted to bring you that
drama from our own Studio courtroom all
the twists and turns from Prince Harry
in the witness box as he put his case
before the judge thanks for watching
for a second day a lot of what he's been
talking about today there's been deeply
personal such a private moment was
turned into a bit of a laugh there was a
difference between public interest and
what interests the public it's been a
grueling a couple of days for him facing
tough tough questioning this is Prince
Harry taking on powerful Fleet Street
tabloids
thank you